what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on super excited
to be talking about civilized to death
we have christopher ryan joining us on
the show thanks hi Chris
how's it going thanks so much for coming
on the program interesting to be here
we're surrounded by technologies
yeah yeah yeah speaking of progress yeah
yeah technology is doing a good job in
some regards and technology is
civilizing us to death in other regards
ain't that the truth ain't that true so
I'm pumped so pumped to have you on to
talk about this and also about that your
other book that you ah co-authored a New
York Times bestseller sex at dawn they
kind of have a lot of overlap and I'm
excited to talk about that overlap for
those who don't know Chris Ryan's
background
he's the New York Times bestselling
co-author of sex at dawn podcast host of
tangentially speaking they've done over
400 episodes now week weekly since 2012
a great podcast take a listen and most
recent author of civilized to death the
price of progress which takes a
contrarian stance that certain aspect to
society's progress may actually be
analogous to advancing a disease all
right and you find all the links in the
Bible Oh to the book and his social
accounts he does a really good job on
his Instagram of keeping people up to
date on his van through Paula G yes
where he anthropology trips yeah he's in
Scarlett Johansson so you know it all
yeah desert outside right now and you do
your podcast on the road as well sure
yeah yeah that's so cool
we host get-togethers so people listen
to the podcast can I'll come and meet
each other and it's all about forming
community right which is something I'm
sure we'll talk about in terms of
prehistory yes yes yes and I want to I
want to jump into things actually from a
very big picture perspective this is
typically what we like really like doing
on our
show let's jump into things from
understanding like we find ourselves
born onto this planet earth and we are
obsessed right now with this question of
trying to influence other people to
think about it more but what is the
ultimate nature of reality why are we
even here in the first place what
created this why are we here and then we
can get into all of the other stuff
related to civilize to death and sex at
dawn but like what are your thoughts
about why are we even here in the first
place and what created this that's where
we're starting yeah all right I'm
normally hi when I talk about yeah what
created this and why are we here well
I'm not an astrophysicist so I can't
answer you know the way Bruce Damer
might have been origins of life and
geysers and all that sort of stuff
but I I don't really know why we're here
and I don't pretend to know and I don't
know what created us I think it's quite
possible that the explanation is
randomness and chaos and out of chaos
comes life and so I don't know I think
terence mckenna's theory that
consciousness that life may be
ubiquitous in the universe but
consciousness spreads by ways of
mushroom by way of mushroom spores for
example and psychedelics I think that is
very interesting to me because there
certainly there's life and then there's
conscious life in there I don't see
evidence that all life leads to
consciously the kind of consciousness
that we experience anyway but then on
the other hand I think unanimous
perspective on life makes a lot of sense
to that everything is alive everything
is imbued with some sort of spiritual
presence and yes so I don't have any
grand theories I don't I don't claim to
be any sort of genius
with you know maybe that disqualifies me
from being on your show but know that uh
you know I think I there are a few
things I feel like I figured out a few
questions I think I've asked in ways
that other people haven't mm-hmm yep and
but I don't think that you know I'm not
qualified to comment on grand questions
you know beyond my own personal
experience I've been thinking about
these grand issues maybe more than then
I had been my father died about a year
ago and he knew he was dying and we had
some interesting conversations leading
up to it and I remember he asked me what
I thought happened after death and my
father was raised Catholic and then lost
his faith in college and then I was born
shortly after her and so his you know
the I forget who said this but someone
said when you're raised in a religious
tradition and then you lose your faith
there's a god-shaped hole in your
consciousness for the rest of your life
like some there's a space that God had
occupied was now empty but the
consciousness is already formed around
it you know anyway I said to my dad that
my feeling about death is that each life
is like a raindrop and that raindrop at
the end of its existence lands on the
sea so the raindrop ceases to exist
but the water that it contained merges
with this greater hole and then the
cycle continues and not necessarily that
raindrop comes back in some sort of you
know Buddhist reincarnation sense but
the essence that was contained in the
raindrop doesn't cease to exist and that
seemed to give him some comfort and it
gives me some comfort and I that that
feels right to me
you know that you know I feel like the
the more we learn about life the more we
realize that everything
is multifactorial everything is
essentially beyond comprehension if you
really go down and dig dig into it yeah
there's a grain of truth in every
perspective so it's yeah you know the
more I know the less I know that's that
kind of thing yeah yet trying to grasp
on to this understanding of what is the
ultimate nature of reality even for
those that are deeply materialist or
evolutionary just to even get to that
initial question of what created the Big
Bang and just trying to scientifically
probe at it and also give room for
spirituality and mysticism and magic
along that journey as well has been
something that I'm just extremely
fascinated with in trying to pass along
to two other people and inspire them
actually like meditation and
psychedelics are a crucial component of
that as well understanding the nature of
reality yeah and even what happens with
near-death experiences what happens
after death what happens before we're
born what are these polarities what are
this interval that seem like our heart
potentially takes these you know two and
a half billion beats of life between
life and death which are so so
interesting and so we just kind of like
obsessively try and push people into
understanding this like do we come here
with a purpose
or a mission you I literally come in in
adventure into consciousness into this
body for this mission of my
consciousness learning these unique
experiences that it's learning and
contributing value to this physical
world that we're endeavoring into and
then do we go and potentially cycle back
into the school again at a later time or
go to other schools and so this is kind
of a very indigenous but also spiritual
but also aiming to be more
scientifically a probe that theme that
we talked about a lot do you have any
thoughts on that last segment that I
just rift on for a moment yeah I mean I
was thinking about the the metaphor of
the raindrop and and how so many
religious traditions sort of come to the
conclusion that
love is the purpose right finding ways
to love and and I'm 57 years old now and
I guess you you reached out to me you
saw me on Brogan's show very recently
and Joe and I were talking about love
and you know I said something that he
initially misunderstood and what I said
was that the older when I was younger I
thought that love was a very scarce
commodity and the older I get the more I
see that it's everywhere yeah and he
misunderstood me to think that I was
talking about dating love like finding a
partner and that kind of thing and and
he made the valid point like hey a lot
of people you know their lives are so
structured they can't they don't have
time and you mean love
in the literal interconnectedness of the
fabric of exist that's what I mean I
mean I mean that the older I get the
more I recognize that and Joe was
talking about this as well that everyone
is lovable everyone is deserving of love
and you see you know Joe was saying that
since having children he looks at
someone now and he sees the little kid
in them he sees the child they were yes
which then creates a sense of compassion
because you can't blame the adult if you
see the child who suffered so much that
he or she got so twisted up into this
person who's annoying or aggressive or
whatever now you see it's ultimately
nothing is anyone's fault it's very
which has radical implications for like
the prison industrial complex and you
know criminal on all that you can
literally look at another human being
and you can see if they're let's say
around 30 days old or so you can
literally see they're almost 10,000 days
of life that they've lived up to that
point and then when you really do that
then you get this love at a deeper level
because you get what are all these
influences and stimuli that have
affected this person's development that
has then made it so that maybe who their
personnel
their traumas their treasures there are
unique gifts that they're bringing to
the world what they're passionate about
their parents and their ancestral
lineage that's it it could even go
previous to their lives we know now that
there are aperture netic alterations
that that come from several generations
back if your grandparents or
great-grandparents suffered from a
famine you're more likely to be obese I
mean it's very there's a lot of
interesting stuff coming out now so yeah
I think the what you were riffing on
there and this question of love again I
think about the raindrops right here we
are were these individual raindrops
falling from the sky in the course of
our lives feeling the separation and yet
the ultimate truth that everyone seems
to arrive at is that we are all one
right we're all the same and that's the
sea that we all came from and that we
all end up in yeah right so maybe this
there's this memory of the unity yeah of
where we are between lives yes right
that we're trying to wake up to it's
like it's like this dream we're in a
dream and the reality is when we're all
one so a lot of people especially when
we talk about you know spirituality or
we talk about psychedelics or meditation
a lot of people talk about this drop
that is able to rejoin the ocean that's
like a really frequent theme that comes
up and I think a really good way to put
it that you're beginning to make it more
and more evident is that it could be
that we come from the ocean of the
clouds in the water cycle resurrected go
into these individual raindrops at
endeavoring into these bodies of
consciousness and then throughout that
process we have the ability to do
meditation or psychedelics or deep
spiritual experiences or even deeply
scientific experiences which take us out
of our individual raindrops and kind of
merge us into that feeling of the
interconnectedness but then third and
then the idea is that as you hit the
ocean that then that is the rejoining
process and then potentially the water
cycle continues is just it's a very
interesting way to push so love is is
both a
yearning for and a memory of and an
experience of that unit unification that
you might experience with individual
other raindrops but what it's really
about is that water all flows into one
and is liquid and this is a temporary
state that we're in now yes and you know
and that's a very important theme I
don't want to push you anywhere you
don't want oh yeah go ahead is a very
important theme in this book actually
because and in sex at dawn honestly I
was about to bring this up let's see
there maybe going into the same place
well this idea that that community is so
deeply important to our species a sense
of being embedded in a in a community of
loving you know mutually respecting
people who are looking out for each
other is so important to the survival of
our species and yet here we are in the
21st century more people living alone
than ever before
the sort of social structure that that
we're living within is separating us and
wants us all to have our individual
spaces because it wants us to spend as
much money as possible on you know
everyone has to have their own washer
and dryer and vacuum cleaner and cars
and television you can't get together
and share it there are literally zoning
laws prohibiting more than one family
from living in a house even if it's a 15
bedroom house
you know it's so that it's the world
that we've created runs so so god
where's your counter to our nature
exactly so that's what this book is
about it's like why have we how have we
ended up in a world that's so hostile to
our deepest needs and and appetites yes
yes and what are the forces behind that
quote-unquote progress and what are the
the really when you follow things like
the money and when you follow things
like people's spirit like what is really
within the further propagation of the
protocols that are making it less
community oriented
robotic and AI driven you know why why
so let's let's um let's hit this from
another perspective and then we're gonna
get into all this it was kind of cool
seeing it from when you were teaching
about it again I was seeing it like the
raindrops have their beautiful
individual relationships to other
raindrops which actually you know
usually people find themselves closest
in terms of love to their you know mom
dad brothers sisters their partner their
spouse right their children these types
of things you're really close as friends
right this type of stuff and so you have
you have to have spokes to all these
other raindrops like nodes you know to
all those other so the spokes to those
other nodes and when you do your wheel
can roll mmm but if any of these spokes
are degraded then your wheel can't roll
through life as easily hmm and so that's
a crucial aspect to these relationships
and then also just let's go to you know
hunter-gatherer days is such a crucial
aspect of your worldview and you like
actually love how you went to this
SuperDuper abstract way of trying to
reconcile what we used to do as
hunter-gatherers and are like
anthropological archaeological lineages
that lead us psychosexual lineages that
lead us to our modern day and trying to
like see how specific aspects of what we
used to do versus what we do now and I
think a good way to put this because
many viewers are quite aware of this
aspect it's just we have people like
Steven Pinker that wrote better angels
of our nature which it just feels like
you know Neil deGrasse Tyson now and all
these other people have just been
telling me every time I've been trying
to probe at certain aspects of that
statement that are you know Michael
Shermer has been another one that we've
had on the show
that we've he's the ultimate skeptic and
we try and poke at like you keep how can
you just blanketly say that a hundred
percent of absolutely everything about
life today is better than it was even
you know ten years ago fifty years ago a
thousand years ago ten thousand a
hundred thousand years ago there's just
a very ignorant I think way to view it
it's it's um it's a little too
it's faith-based yeah yeah that's what I
find ironic about it that it's you know
there's a thing a section in the book
here where I place Richard Dawkins in a
pulpit you know because so much of his
thinking as I read it is faith-based
it's it doesn't stand up to scrutiny and
I think that's true of Steven Pinker of
Matt Ridley and you know that I call
them the Neo Hobbs Ian's who begin with
the assumption that life is getting
better and has always gotten better with
you know fits and starts and minor
setbacks here and there but in general
the trend has always been better better
better and you know I take apart of the
rational optimist which is a book
written by Matt Ridley which basically
makes that argument you know it's
explicitly the argument of the book and
it's incredible when you see the the
twists that they put themselves in to
make this argument so Matt Ridley says
there's a right at the beginning of the
book where he's saying look life is
clearly getting better first of all you
know we went from species with fifty
thousand a hundred thousand individuals
to seven billion you know I mean come on
that's progress
and and I'm ovulation is from you know
how is having more of us better
for us it might be better for some other
super organism that you know but I will
argue the creativity the meaning the
amount of interconnectedness can get
expressed it's some mash or and those
are interesting arguments to make and
and then I would have responses to each
of those yeah yeah but the the idea that
more of a species makes it a more
successful species is only relevant in a
very limited biological sense that the
DNA of that species is spreading in that
sense that's success but that says
nothing about the experience of
individuals within that speech like and
also the 10 million total species and
how chickens and pigs and cows are just
getting slaughtered right right and
there are more of them so they must be
better off
so like this would be maybe a good way
to maybe try and quantify it would be
like for the humans at least out of the
a billion of us today if you could have
maybe a score for their overall health
and wellness and prosperity their
overall score of one to a hundred let's
say would the then average of the you
know 1 million people that used to live
a hundred thousand years ago would the
average collective score be 65 or 85 or
today would it be 65 or 85 where do
those scores rank yeah I I think I I
don't claim to be able to answer that
question definitively yeah but I think
that it's a very important question it's
an important question which is dismissed
by the face re-sprout it's a it's a
relevant question and it's a complicated
question for example in the last ten
days I saw a report from UNICEF that
said one of three children alive in the
world today is malnourished one in three
so like 2.5 billion children are
malnourished that's a lot of kids yeah
if we've been having progress for
thousands of years since the advent of
civilization five seven ten thousand
years whatever your measure is ha this
is as far as we've gotten one out of
three kids is malnourished to the point
where their bodies aren't developing
their brains aren't developing properly
that's insane but there's no way that
we've been progressing and if you look
at hunter-gatherer kids
what you find is very little mal
nourishment
almost no mal nourishment and I quote
you know primary sources with the hodza
in Africa and tribes in the Amazon
anthropologist that went specifically to
look at the health of children and they
find these kids are great no parasites
no no even older people no heart disease
no diabetes none of this stuff now I'm
not whitewashing hunter-gather existence
a lot of kids die yeah yeah they die the
child mortality rate is very high
actually you bring up the statistic
which i think is really interesting
quickly to mention is that a lot of
people just say oh we used to live 30
years 35 years used to be the average
life expectancy now you're living 75 so
yeah progress progress progress double
the human lifespan doubled the human
lifespan is sorry but then that this is
such a fascinating ideas that did that
took into account child mortality rates
which were significantly higher so you
would average in someone that dies at
one with someone that dies at 70 which
is why that number seems so low right
compared to today but really if we can
look back at anthropological and
archaeological records could it be that
a lot of people that were healthy were
living until they were 70 just like they
are today definitively there there's no
question about it
so a human being has never been old at
35 except maybe Mark Zuckerberg I don't
know but yeah human Beast sorry if he's
a listener or watch other but no human
beings Homo sapiens are average lifespan
beyond childhood or let's say our modal
lifespan the time the number of years at
which your body starts to break down and
if you don't die from one thing you're
gonna die from something else is between
70 and 80 that's natural forest
chimpanzees live typically into their
50s as do bonobos so the idea that's
been a constant a pretty constant
chimpanzees bonobos the other thing
about 50 since the dawn of time right
interesting so they're they haven't
really had a like a life expectancy
uptick so we basically need really true
radical life longevity with things like
a
taking our like 15 year old homeostatic
capacity our body's ability to get back
to equilibrium and we need to have that
when we're 25 and 35 and 45 in order for
our body to constantly be able to come
combat against pathology developing in
order for us to uptake ourselves up to
120 or 160 in terms of life expectancy
which then make it so that now we're
talking real longevity increases yeah
I'm very skeptic I know you've had
Aubree on the show yeah yeah yeah I'm
very skeptical of that that whole
Silicon Valley movement or eternal life
it's a bunch of [ __ ] honestly but I
mean just to finish this yeah so so what
people are led to believe and I taught
in medical schools in Spain where my
students believed that you know and I
quote doctors for UCSF like very elite
institution a doctor they're saying well
the reason that people have chronic back
problems is that the human body wasn't
designed to last this long people died
in their mid-30s in prehistory and so
that's their so people educated
clinicians who are working with these
issues believe that the human body was
not designed to last beyond 40 that's
not true that is factually incorrect and
no one who understands this data is is
confused about this this is an
archeologists anthropologists they all
understand this but when it comes into
popular culture it's a very powerful
idea because it feels good mmm oh yeah
we've done so well we doubled our
lifestyle so whatever problems you have
you're not happy at work you feel like
your life is slipping away from you you
don't have any friends you're your
body's all messed up because this shitty
food that you're eating
look you're living twice as long the
sales pitch to get people to stop
complaining it's what it is you're
depressed because the you feel like a
dopamine monkey behind your cell phone
right stop complaining you're living
toys what so me my point once I
establish this this that this is a
statistical statistically misleading
factoid I say if you're gonna count a
child mortality in your average let's
count abortion hmm abortion doesn't
enter into our average lifespan
calculations why not right and this is
no commentary on the ethical arguments
around abortion I'm just saying a lot of
the kids who died in prehistory before
won a lot of the skeletons that appear
in these archaeological finds were
children who were born who were
unhealthy who had birth defects and
hunter-gatherers would have let them die
what do we do we detect them in prenatal
testing and abort them so hmm
why isn't that a relative or a relevant
factor in our calculation so we've been
practicing eugenics and some sorts for
the longest time and we want to preserve
millions of babies are aborted around
the world at the number every year I
don't know the numbers in the book out
of hundreds in China and India girls are
aborted healthy female fetuses are
aborted regularly in China because of
the one-child policy and everyone wants
to have a son so now we've got hundreds
of millions of boys without you know
girls yeah and in India just because of
cultural bias against girls and toward
boys one child policy did just end yeah
yeah yeah so anyway the the the the real
relevance of that argument is I would
say twofold one is just I want people to
understand no hunter-gatherers live into
their 70s and this this notion that
we've doubled the human lifespan is
bogus and much of the actual extension
in our lives and related back to my
father isn't is not in liveable life
it's we die more slowly so it's like
it's like basket
ball games you know you watch this
basketball game it's dramatic it goes
back and forth it's really exciting and
then in the final like minute and a half
it takes half an hour because of the
timeout another TV commercial they know
they've got your attention you're not
going to change the channel you want to
see who wins and the whole the whole
like meaning of the game is in the last
minute and a half two minutes and it
takes half an hour
it ruins the drama ruins the experience
of the game that's what we've done with
our lives we we that we've got a medical
profession that is operating under the
assumption that death is the enemy to be
fought constantly at any cost in human
suffering and in material sense it's
absurd it's absurd and you know I had to
actually call my my father's doctor and
say what are you doing the guy 79 years
old he's got kidney disease he's got
heart disease he's you know he's on his
way out and you're ordering more tests
you're ordering more therapies you're
sending him around the city to get all
these treatments let the dude die right
I know he's got great insurance and I
know you're getting a lot of money out
of that but enough right you're
torturing him for money for no reason
you know and I think a lot of people are
facing that kind of situation in the
United States and other countries it's
it's different but in the United States
yeah that palliative terror man
perspective is actually really important
we had just sit around the show she was
talking about these these end-of-life
conversations that we need to have with
our loved ones where what if what if I
literally just don't want to go through
that process like you're indicating
about your father
maybe I do want to just go out to the
ocean or to the forest and I want that
experience with a couple people that are
close to me as I pass breath and like to
have these so called like that sounds
way more like hunter-gatherer ask and
that sounds of way less like corporate
metropolis transactional esque and so
yeah and also we need to we need to hit
this point this points so important
you mentioned this and I think this is
again just such a crucial aspect to the
conversation which is this idea that
like we're being in a sense propagandize
propaganda is coming down our throats
all the time about this is the best time
to live period shut up you have all the
best things now and it just basically
takes us away from observing how it
could have been better that what are the
better aspects of how hunter-gatherers
lived and before we get to this idea of
like okay these aspects are better which
you are already talking about but that
these aspects were better these aspects
are worse about about today we can bring
some of these aspects from what we were
doing in the past and we can actually
implement them into what we are doing
today to make life better one of the
things you brought up was community
already right but especially as we build
these AIS and we build the robotic age
and the biotech and neuro tech age and
the VR age and all these quantum
computing ages that we're building it
can actually be extremely beneficial for
us to fish back and find the
interconnectedness of everything fish
back and find our connection to nature
fish back and find our connection to
each other into community and and just
embed ethics and morals and philosophy
and spirituality in the the technologies
that we're building of tomorrow
that are treating humans like they're
obsolete and instead treat humans like
the divine beings that they are yeah I
wonder if that's possible though I
wonder like in your construction we're
building the technologies I kind of feel
like the technologies are building us
you know I feel like you know the
Michael Pollan makes this point in one
of his books that you know you could say
that humans have used wheat and they're
you know there's wheat all over the
world because it's useful to humans but
you could also look at and say no wheat
has used humans to spread itself getting
back to this question of you know is the
absolute number of a species
measure of its progress if so wheat has
been incredibly successful in something
even older than that is our microbiome
sure yeah yeah so there-there are these
questions of who's using drone yeah
what's happening here
you're all so interconnected like that
if it was using well like that yeah I
mean there's a whole section of this
book that I ended up taking out mostly
because my editor was like dude that's a
whole different book you know you can't
just slip this in here but I got to the
point where I was I'm making the
argument like okay civilization actually
on aggregate in my opinion is not an
improvement in human life like you were
talking about earlier if we assign sort
of a more life human life satisfaction
score you know the average around the
world right now would probably be pretty
low whereas in hunter-gatherer times the
average was pretty high people you talk
to any you know any case where the
hunter-gatherers are offered the
opportunity to join civilization they
flee yeah I tell a story about Darwin
and on the ship there were these three
people who had been brought to to
England and met the Queen and saw how
they have civilized people lived and the
idea was they're taking them back to
Tierra del Fuego and they would put them
there with a house and a garden and they
would tell the native people like no no
we should be nice to those and British
people because they've got the greatest
life they really know how to live and
instead they abandon the house abandoned
the gardens and just fled back and lived
the way they had and they got Jemmy
buttons when they Darwin and the crew
were back there they found this guy and
they brought him on the ship and he had
lived in England for a year too he you
know spoke English and he and Darwin
wrote in his journal that he was very
pleased to see that at least he still
remembered how to use a knife and spoon
and fork and all that and they said to
him like why did you abandon the gardens
and the huts we built and all this stuff
and and he's in and they offered to take
him back to England if you want to come
what you can come with us England he's
like he said no man there are plenty
birdies plenty fishies he's like
why do you guys want me to work I don't
understand or the guy in the Kalahari
who said the King Sandman who said why
should I learn to farm when there are so
many [ __ ] [ __ ] nuts in the world like
hunter-gatherers look at the world and
they say I got everything I need here
this is fine I'm happy we're good
it's the civilization people from
civilization who want to impose who
insist it's like you know white man's
burden we have to go and civilize them
we have to show them this is the way to
live you have to live this way God won't
forgive you for being a heathen you have
to join us
that's the insistence right it's not
coming in the other way the other the
other way they're like hey we're good
you do what you do just leave us alone
right so it's a very interesting sort of
flip where you know these neo Hobbs
Ian's and and then go back in time the
the missionaries and you know all that
sort of explorers they're all out there
pushing this way of life that they think
is superior so clearly superior and yet
you have to literally kill people
destroy their culture in order for them
to submit to this way of life that's so
superior it doesn't make any sense
logically you know I quote from Darwin's
letters that he wrote back to the KN
Queen of Spain on his first voyage de
Spain Yola and he he writes about how
amazing the people are he says they're
they're beautiful they're healthy
there's food and fish everywhere all the
trees have fruit it's like they live in
paradise in fact some historians have
argued that the word Indian doesn't come
from the idea that Columbus thought he
was in India it comes from the fact that
in these letters he said seguramente s
gente que viven en Dios in Dios and Neos
in right in God and God exactly right
and paradise in heritage
because they had so much abundance they
had abundance they were happy they were
generous if you express admiration and
he says this if you express admiration
for any possession they immediately give
it to you they're they're ignorant of
war he says they're the the I forget the
phrase but it roughly it's their the the
most beautiful people in the world and
then the next sentence he says with
fifty men I could subjugate them all so
who's living the superior life there
right who's got the better approach what
if Columbus and his men had just been
like you know what the hell with Spain
we're staying here which happens which
happened many times actually in the
course of history the mutiny on the
bounty was an example of that where the
men on the ship mutiny because they
wanted to stay on that island rather
than go back to England and continue
their miserable lives on that ship so
there are many historical examples of
this sort of thing some of which I cited
in the book here I don't remember what
your question what a mosaic picture
perspective on this big board game we
like thinking about it like a big game
of Sims or a big game of Risk and
monopoly that we're all embedded in and
in that sense it's like you know you're
sending out the ships because in many
ways are you going out with a big loving
heart to try and go and and and trade
with other people around the world and
learn about who they are and see what
their what they've creatively made or
are you going there to literally push
your religion and dogmas and try and
just pillage their resources and try and
take over their land with your army and
you know do the little risk movement
where you get your color on their land
and I think that you know sometimes like
you indicated they come and they see
that Wow is it really this beautifully
interconnected with nature their lives
and so much abundance and so much
prosperity that maybe we should just
stay here
and and and then I think this also is
really important to mention it's just
that a lot of people will say well don't
be so in love with the past because
there were aspects of the past that
weren't so pretty as well and I think
that's also very true and very important
although you do disprove some of those
things you say that all the people that
say that there are issues with dental
hygiene that dental hygiene wasn't an
issue in the hunter-gatherer days it
only became an issue when we started
eating grains in our in our agricultural
domestication agrarian days and that and
so did there's things like that but
there there's also like in a sense it
one day something did happen where it
was a alan has this stuff and claims
it's his stuff and chris has this stuff
and claims it's his stuff and then I'm
like well why does Chris have more stuff
than me why is his wife prettier and why
does he have a bigger cave Bop on the
head and so there was that as well so
there's like that but it's compared to
also this beautiful interconnectedness
yeah but also let's look at that a
little closer because in terms of the
metaphor that you're using Chris has
more stuff than me so we're talking
about culture with accumulated resources
hunter-gatherers don't have accumulated
resource there's nomadic and no matter
that to the spot exactly a harvesting
and then just thinking what they need
what they find and they use it it's the
the technical term is immediate return
hunter-gatherers so immediate rich
immediate return so they find fruit they
eat it right they kill something they
eat it and then they move on the next
day there's no fridge no fridge they're
not now the the the other rain like
agriculture is no grain and and a more
relevant example would be the Pacific
Northwest people who had massive salmon
runs seasonally and they learned to
smoked salmon and so they would harvest
the salmon during the salmon run
Oh get and then they would have that in
the winter to heat now what happened so
that's sort of like in agricultural
since there's some overfishing that
occurred then not the overfishing but
they became hierarchical warlike women
became very low status they had slavery
so they essentially became like
agricultural society so it's the
accumulated resources that triggers this
political change and the change in the
relationships between men and women and
other human beings because now you have
possessions when you have possessions
you need to decide who gets to keep them
who gets to distribute them you know who
protects them who so you you get these
political hierarchies that develop very
quickly
damn so that's the trigger moment is you
know as you start smoking the salmon and
you're able to store it longer then it's
like well why does he have six Salmons
and I only have one over the winter and
and then and so that's so interesting so
as soon as there's like possessions I'm
one more time was immediate need
immediate return immediate return again
these others in the Pacific Northwest
are technically referred to as complex
hunter-gatherers comp what they're not
really hunter gathers that's the thing
so yeah and the this is you know you
mentioned Steven Pinker earlier he plays
with this stuff there's immediate return
hunter-gatherers which is what our
ancestors were right there may have been
some complex under gatherers in some
parts of the world but they would have
been limited to areas with a salmon run
or something like that right and we're
presuming they learned how to smoked
salmon and preserve it no one really
knows for sure so you got immediate
return complex then you have Corte
culturalist who have the hunt and fish
but they also have Gardens domesticated
animals pigs normally and like in Papua
New Guinea and they build static
settlement so they build a longhouse or
they build buildings that are meant to
be there for a long time it's not a
teepee or a wigwam or something that you
stay in at night or two
and then either break down and take with
you or just abandon now the complex
under gathers and the horticulturalist
they have resources they have
accumulated resource yes you've got pigs
you've got a building you've got gardens
so you've got something worth fighting
so hierarchies form you can see the
evolution of a hierarchy starting as
resources accumulate that's it a
hierarchy forms in response to the
presence of accumulated resources that's
so right so then when you get into these
discussions of whether or not war was
ubiquitous in prehistory which Steven
Pinker and Richard Dawkins and Michael
Shermer are very sort of adamant about
my question to them is why do you think
people were risking their lives to fight
when there was nothing worth fighting
over
there were no resources so I understand
if you've got a garden and you've got
pigs and you know over in our valley the
the rains don't come and so there is not
enough to eat the trees aren't fruiting
we might come over and raid your your
village to get some of those pigs we're
starving of course we are right but if
you don't have any pigs if you're like
us and you're just moving around
even the intermediate return there's
nothing to get from you yeah yeah right
you have nothing except maybe some of
these other maybe you found a couple
pieces of gold somewhere or you found a
couple gold is there's no value to
hunter-gatherers that's a civilizational
thing you maybe you found some sort of a
better weapon that can that can a that
can kill the animal that you're looking
to hunt up some obsidian or some City
and so there may be something that they
have in a even in an immediate return
hierarchy that makes it so that people
would want to commit violence maybe I
don't think so that's much less possible
than what you indicate which is that as
soon as you have a you called it what
we're the next ones hoard the
horticultural societies were cultural
societies so that that creates then the
smoked salmon examples greater also the
just an accumulation of resources at all
begins yeah that purse some things great
something worth fighting over
remember hunter-gatherers are all armed
they're all armed all are and they know
how to use those weapons right they hunt
so it's very risky to attack a group of
hunter-gatherers they're very alert
they're armed
they're very fit they're gonna chase you
down they're gonna shoot you it's not a
low-risk proposition these are not like
we call today keyboard warrior right
yeah it's not a bunch of angry dudes on
Twitter as dude yeah so yeah so anyway
that that's a an interesting sort of
argument about war I would love for
everything that you just said that is
challenging the current zeitgeist around
what Pinker Dawkins a Shermer etc are
propagating I would love for that to be
a discussion that's actually had I would
love to see that on a show like ours are
on Rogen show or wherever it ends up
being but I would love to have and I
think Shermer actually had it also with
remind me again a gobekli tepe who was
the author again of of the no now Graham
Hancock Graham Hancock thank you thank
you for getting that one for me yeah
that uh that Shermer had it with Graham
Hancock at least on the program on Rogan
John Rogan show yeah yeah so those two
got the chance to go back and forth grow
and yeah and I've had Michael Shermer on
my podcast twice I think yeah and I will
be on his in the next couple of weeks
great and he's already and I actually I
warned him I was like dude you know you
might have had a chance to read civilize
to death but I definitely take some
shots at Pinker and Dawkins and I know
you're friends with them so I know heads
up but in a friendly way this isn't like
again this isn't shots like we're trying
to like be like commit harm against each
other it's just
literally like we want to settle the the
world views the world views in the sense
are like hey we want to get to the truth
everyone's trying to get to the truth
and if we can write out these core
points about what you're saying the
truth is what we think it is and then
just see how those can interplay and
find some sort of a really cohesive
thing where they can give examples and
say actually hunter-gatherers behaved in
this way and you can go they behaved in
that way I think that can be really
helpful but you know just the discourse
needs to happen rather than again it
just seems like it's a dogmatic
faith-based idea in progress that all
progress 100% not even 99.9% 100% of
everything that's happened until today
has been exceptional and all the
progress and so yes it does definitely
like like we were saying if you look
back and see the interconnectedness the
respect to nature the one thing and
trying to embed that in what we're doing
in the future but one thing that I do
really have to mention with you that I
thought so also fascinating I was
recently hanging out with one of my
friends Miche and she has a she has a
chicken she has a chicken coop I'm she
has chickens and she was teaching me
about chicken hierarchies which are
ridiculously pecking order pecking
orders and and so she goes uh she was
the roosters are pretty serious
regarding like getting into the the sex
with hens and and and I was like okay
well tell me more ensure goes well
sometimes when when two roosters have
both contributed to the hen contribute
contribute as in semen to the hen that
the hen will birth then the the chicken
that will birth from the hen will
literally have visible genetic traits
from both roosters hmm and that blew my
[ __ ]
you know because you list this tribe in
the Amazon lots of lots of tribes in the
Amazon and around the world that again
we have this again let me put this into
perspective we have this very purist
idea where I know people of specific
nationalities even my own nationality
which is like Armenian and where my
literally family friends will say things
like I will not have sex with a woman
that has had sex with anyone she has to
be a virgin she has to be a hundred
percent Armenian and then and only then
will I have a child with her because she
is pure and I know that my seed is gonna
be 100 percent Armenian and I'm like
damn that is some straight-up crazy
cultural lineage [ __ ] that that is it
and verses like these tribes in the
Amazon are like what these chicken
examples is that a woman can go and find
the smartest guy the strongest guy the
funniest guy and have sex with all of
them in a short period of time and then
the child can basically potentially be
33 and 1/3 percent from all three of
those dads and all three of them feel
like they need to you know what an
insane difference from managua right
yeah right yeah anthropologists refer to
that as part of all paternity partible
pattern and it's seen in at least half a
dozen tribes in the Amazon that have no
connection with one another no trading
or common language or anything so it's
clear that it has arisen in different
parts of the world also Papua New Guinea
and there are indications in other parts
of the world as well so it's it appears
to be sort of a natural conclusion
people didn't understand Darwin didn't
understand that one sperm cell was
sufficient to impregnate a woman you
know so that's a pretty relative
relatively recent understanding so why
would you make that connection if women
are generally having sex and getting
pregnant why would you conclude that the
sex made them pregnant
it rains a lot and women get pregnant
you don't say rain causes pregnancy
right and we talked to insects at dawn
we talked about parts of the world where
there's the belief that if a woman steps
over a smoky fire that'll get her
pregnant or that the ancestral spirits
just come down and inhabit a woman and
so in in the partible paternity case
they believe that women are partly
pregnant when they begins to menstruate
and that's an indication that there's a
person possibly forming in there but
they don't they sort of reach a tipping
point when a critical mass of semen is
accumulated so she has to have a certain
amount of sex with men and then the
semen literally congeals into a fetus
Wow
yeah and so that's why the the essence
of the different men that she's had sex
with become materially and spiritually
part of that child so when the child's
born and all the men who have had sex
with her will feel a paternal connection
to that to that baby you know and the
over operative breeding was the other
one
partly the Eternity cooperative Bria
interest and cooperative raising of
children to think about then the child
gets the really strong dad the really
smart dad's really funny dad to race
help and they get to do that for all the
communal rights because that's not the
only woman that those guys have been
having sex with so there's this you know
the the overarching argument of sex at
dawn is that our ancestors survived by
cooperating with one another right and
this gets us back to the raindrops and
the love and as you know you know unity
and all these things we know without
question immediate return
hunter-gatherer societies are organized
around the principle of sharing and
cooperation now for people who say uh
you know here we go with the Rousseau II
and you know the noble savage stuff I
want to make it very clear that that
what anthropologists have demonstrated
is
that hunter-gatherers are more noble
than we are in some sense it's that
sharing enabled them to survive it was
simply the most practical approach to
organizing a hunter-gatherer society and
hunter-gatherer societies constitute
well more than 95% of our existence of
our time in existence as a species I'm
talking about anatomically modern human
beings I'm not even getting into you
know previous versions of Homo sapiens
yeah we're talking out of the last
200,000 years only 10,000 was
agriculture and now that since I since
sexathon was published that estimates
gone to 300 thousand there have been
discoveries in North Africa that seemed
to indicate that anatomically modern
humans existed 300,000 years ago so yeah
10,000 years out of 300,000 and that's
you know in the Fertile Crescent that's
not in most parts of the world where
civilization came later we're talking
about you know if you want to understand
your dog you look at wolves and coyotes
right that's the essence even though
your dog might be a poodle or a pug its
essence is a carnivore it's a it's a
canid and so that's what you know that's
what you want to study if you want to
understand us you study hunter-gatherers
that's what we are a study your lineage
study the past in order to understand
who you are or and where you can
optimally go and you want to understand
what kind of life is gonna be satisfying
and meaningful for this creature yes you
know I use the zoo metaphor in the book
where you know we are gonna live in a
zoo as you're saying what are we gonna
do in the future what how are we going
to design our world so that it'll be
more healthy and satisfying for us as as
a species well we need to understand the
world in which we evolve yes right just
like if you're designing a zoo you want
to design the enclosure to replicate as
much as possible the natural environment
of that
so that it won't die or you know become
suicidal or insane zu kosis is a term
used by zoo designers and workers for
animals that are so out of place they
lose their minds right so do we want to
live in that Calcutta Zoo which is just
a bunch of concrete boxes or do we want
to live in the San Diego Zoo that's
designed around an understanding of the
species we design the zoos that we live
in we do so our cities our cities our
office buildings the way we design
corporations the way we design
hierarchies the way we practice politics
yes the food that would eat yes right
all of this is is the result of choices
that we make and if we make those
choices informed by the sort of animal
that we actually are not the propaganda
that we're hearing telling us
everything's great everything's better
than it's ever been
don't look back that's the zookeeper
telling the animal in the cage to just
shut up and be happy yeah you're lucky
you're protected by your cage yeah yeah
yeah keep stay heads down and keep
building the prison walls that that are
the metropolis that are the the the zoo
cages that are not as efficiently built
as they could potentially be and I
really like that analogy a lot the zoo
analogy is really good because we are
the designers of the built environment
that we have the opportunity to put
ourselves in and if we took that really
reflective step that needs to be taken
to see where we came from and how we
could add these first principled methods
of living with nature harmoniously with
the interconnected fabric of each other
at a deeper level with more community
with more love with more sharing with
all these different things and if we
embed that going forward you know our
cities would look completely different
our hierarchies would look completely
different our politics and our economics
would look completely different and one
of those things is this idea of
inclusive stake holding
that's something that is looking like
more and more is the direction of where
we're going we are no longer looking at
things from a actually this is really
applicable to hundred gatherers to is
just that it used to be that I would
tell you a story because it would
benefit our collective genetic fitness
for me to tell you that story about what
to eat what not to eat about how to hunt
about how to love how to be funny how to
be strong etc now stories are propaganda
for self dealing habits and I will tell
you a story so that you buy my [ __ ] hmm
and my [ __ ] isn't always conducive to
your genetic fitness you like these big
this big picture view so yes I'll talk
about you with something that I don't
normally talk about in interviews
because it's too far out remember I said
earlier there's a part of the book I had
to pull out because the editor said no
that's a totally different book it was
examining this question of why is
civilization so powerful if it's
actually not improving the quality of
life for the average human being and as
I investigated that question I I started
to see evidence
you mentioned the microbiome earlier
right so there's there's like a sort of
a hierarchy of life you have
single-celled organisms you know Bruce
Damer spoken about where how they may
have arisen converting solar energy into
biological energy then you have
multicellular organisms then you might
have like groups of multicellular
organisms that function in some way
collectively and so on and so on and it
increases in complexity and at the
pinnacle of complexity we place
ourselves because that's the way humans
tend to do things and so here we are at
the pinnacle of complexity all this
other each stage of life is composed of
simpler stages of life
right it's each so but here we are we
contain billions of cells in our guts
and on our skin and in our blood and on
in the liquid over our eyeballs and all
these cells are
that don't even share our DNA so each of
us we act as if were individuals but
each of us as is in fact a complex
system with billions of interacting
organisms yeah each of us is a city
right yes yes why do we think it stops
there why do we think that that's the
end of it starts with single cell and it
ends with humans mm-hmm that seems
unlikely to me so my question was okay
what are we embedded within what other
life form are we part of that we're
unaware of just like these organisms
within us have no idea that there's
somebody driving to Starbucks to get a
coffee right yes and I came to the
conclusion that institutions and more
broadly civilization itself is an
organism it's an emergent intelligence
within which we're embedded so you know
what example I am seeing it as the the
whole planet itself is if the eight
billion human cells but it's also all of
the other ten million species that are
on the planet and then they act as nodes
as well but the whole earth orbiting
this star is a cell in the universe
right I mean the sort of Gaia hypothesis
there's a beautiful book of lives of a
cell by Lewis Thomas that's like one of
the classics of scientific literature
from the 70s where he really gets into
this notion but I'm thinking of it more
as I mean yes the that's certainly true
but for example I was thinking yeah I
was talking with someone about this and
about exon and I co-hosts and Co created
this thing called the [ __ ]
Awards that happens in LA or this will
be the second year December 3rd and the
idea is to celebrate the corporations
that have done the best work [ __ ]
mother earth so right Oh comedians
accept the rewards on
Awards on behalf of the corporations so
we have these you know great la-based
comedians who go and accept the award so
it's for humorously to awaken people to
like corruption in to environmental
pollution exactly right so it's it's a
lot of fun
it's trying to laugh at the dire state
that we're in you know trying to bring
comedy to it but bring awareness to
these things that are happening right
anyway I was talking with somebody in in
that context and they said you know
Chris the thing is like good people work
at these companies like there are good
people working at Exxon and you
demonizing them and I'm not talking
about the people I'm talking about exon
exon as an entity right or DuPont or
Monsanto or whatever it is and the thing
is Exxon is a living thing
so if the head of Exxon if a CEO of
Exxon goes down to Peru with his son and
does some ayahuasca and has an epiphany
and suddenly sees the world as you and I
do and realizes what what's going on and
what his role in that has been and he
goes back to headquarters and has a
meeting on Monday morning saying
gentlemen we need to stop this we can't
do this deepwater drilling we can't be
on the North Slope we have no idea what
we're doing we can't protect the planet
with what's gonna happen he's out he's
out before lunch and what if the Board
of Directors happens to agree with him
they're out what if the whole company
goes and does ayahuasca exactly what
would happen they would all be fired and
other people would replace them because
people don't run companies companies run
people that's my point
civilization does not serve us we serve
civilization there's something going on
here on a macro level that we're barely
able to perceive whatever gets trying to
imagine the big game yeah where were or
another analogy would be termites every
every termites doing something that
seems to make sense to him and somehow
is
and termite mound is built yes yes right
salmon schooling birds flocking nobodies
nobody knows what's happening it just
happened it seems like as Yan said a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence well that's one of the
possibilities that I'm not real happy
about but certainly it feels as if we
may be a larval stage for another
life-form that's emerging out of us
that's sort of a merging of technology
and biology we already see it you know
with the artificial hips and the
pacemakers and the LASIK surgery and the
implanted lenses and the Google glasses
and you know all this staring at our
phones we've act you know externalized a
lot of our brain functioning it seems to
be going in that direction and that
doesn't bode well for us because that
life-form doesn't need clean oceans or
fisheries or coral reefs or any of the
other things that we value as human
beings so at the end of civilized to
death I sort of go down I look at three
potential futures and that's one of them
this if we keep going the direction
we're going it's a further merging of
our biology with a technology and a
continued destruction of the natural
environment it doesn't have to go that
way it can be the merging with
technology and have it be very
spiritually ethically morally
philosophically grounded in
interconnectedness with nature it can be
both it could but I tend to agree with
Tristan Harris's view of technology
which is that it's not neutral it has an
agenda that's built into it and
generally the agenda of Technology is
not in alignment with the things that
make people happy and feel meaningful
and involved I think technology
generally favors the centralization and
concentration of power and resources
which is what we're seeing right
with greater income inequality and
wealth inequality in the United States
then has existed ever in the history of
this country the technology is not
creating it's not dispersing resources
more equitably you know we every time
they sell it to us they tell us that's
what its gonna do right Airbnb is gonna
help everybody Hoover is gonna help
everybody it's the sharing economy but
somehow the resources end up not being
shared well that's the inclusive stake
holding solution of your time but
earlier literally where the drivers get
tokens as well as the customers that
take the car rides get tokens that then
earn an inclusive stake holding
membership ownership of the the fruits
that are being created by the the gig
economy and that is a massive part to
our future and that same thing can be
applied to teachers and their students
it can be applied to physicians and
their patients this inclusive stake
holding idea and then it makes it so
that at least the benefits of the big
merging with technology are a more
interconnected with nature we keep that
but also the fruits are shared with all
people as best as possible what are the
other two potential options that you
well one was sort of Mad Max
post-apocalyptic you know nightmare
scenario where you know a global
economic and ecological collapse and we
end up in some sort of a you know crazy
horrible period of you know cannibalism
and whatever else is in that movie but
the third which is the one I really hope
that we can achieve it involves the
hero's journey you know Joseph Campbell
a hero the Thousand Faces so joseph
campbell explained is that the great
mythologist explained that every society
around the world has essentially the
same origin myth which is a narrative of
a young person going out and you know
think of the Odyssey right having
experiences
eating strange characters learning
lessons facing challenges almost dying
etc and then returning and bringing back
the knowledge yes that has been received
on that journey I quote TS Eliot toward
the end of the book there's a great line
from the Four Quartets where he wrote we
shall not cease our explorations and the
end of all our exploring will be to
return to where we began and know the
place for the first time I love that one
yeah it's so beautiful beautiful yeah or
the the line from Whitman that I began
with I'd never I just happened upon it
I'm glad you have both Whitman and Eliot
in there that's yeah he says the
friendly and flowing Savage who is he is
he waiting for civilization or past it
and mastering it mmm right so there's
this sense that as a species it feels to
me as if we've been on this journey
right we left home when we developed
Agron when agriculture started that's
when we left home the Garden of Eden all
these these myths of the lost paradise
are racial memories of the
hunter-gatherer life where the gods
provided for us they weren't angry
vengeful gods This Old Testament God
that you and I have grown up with they
were gods that were that were nourishing
and friendly and the mother earth gave
right took care of it was then then the
angry father came on the scene and you
they'll shout you know thou shalt eat by
the sweat of thy brow that shall give
birth and pain and agony you know all
this like angry and and difficult
experience began with agriculture the
struggle began with agriculture and this
is where I disagree profoundly with
Richard Dawkins and the Neo Hobbs Ian's
who claim that life before this state
before civilization was a constant
struggle there's no evidence for
no anthropologist has shown this
hunter-gatherers work on average 20
hours a week and what and what we're
calling work which they have no word for
in their language is hunting fishing and
gathering food things that we do on
vacation you know so there's no evidence
that the life was a struggle before
agriculture it certainly has been a
struggle ever since well when you when
you can't find the next patch of food
it's a you have to well there were some
difficulties there were brief periods of
hunger we can read the bones in it in
archaeological digs that show that
hunter-gatherer nutrition is high is
much better than agriculturalists
they were bigger people if you look at
the bones just before and just after
agriculture arose in different regions
you see universally indications of
nutritional deficiencies in the
agriculturalists and their teeth in
their bones you see evidence of
prolonged famine you don't see these
things in the hunter-gatherers because
they're eating 75 different types of
plants and animals they're not dependent
on one so if the crop fails there's no
problem for hunter-gatherers they don't
have a crop it's the agriculturalists
who are very dependent upon this anyway
the point the the larger point I was
making as far as the three scenarios is
yes there's the the continued merging of
biology and technology the sort of Elan
musk we have to go to Mars scenario
there's that everything just falls apart
and we're you know revert to some sort
of horrible desperate struggle for
survival scenario the third scenario is
that we're on this hero's journey as a
species we've gone out we've learned
very important things we've learned
birth control which is very wisely so
it's like we heroes journey out into
cities and metropolis to this and we're
gonna challenge learn from it and go
home
right and we're it feels to me that
we're at this point we're at the most
distant point now and we as a species
are turning toward home because we're
realizing how precarious things are yeah
we're seeing how far from home we've
gone and how much we're suffering now of
course my perspective is very biased
right but I see evidence of this all
around you know I met whole mental
mental health suicide dude a
cardiovascular disease cancer diabetes
like health-wise were a mess right
there's no doubt we're at the richest
country in the history of the world and
we are a mess
we're addiction you know addictive
behaviors prison populations I mean this
is a disaster
any way you look at it and yet people it
seems to me but this equipments pretty
good to let us oh sure there's like
these there's always this interesting
dichotomous struggle that happens
between what we're what we're saying
like that mental health and that this
issue but then it's like ah but this
equipments enabling us to talk about it
so so we can do what we could have
talked about it sitting around a fire
the equipment doesn't allow us this ha
but this equipment enables it to be
communicated the memes can spread to
millions of people around the planet and
then in take that into the world view
and go [ __ ] that I'm with you I think
the best thing is on a par with the
invention of the printing yeah exactly
so we have to balance these things out
so the ideas how do we take the X so
that's what I'm saying that's why I
think we're turning toward home yeah
because here we are we've got for the
first time we've got this this
interconnected global brain so things so
memes ideas can spread in an hour they
can go everywhere right you and I I
assume there's no company between us and
the audience really except YouTube and
Facebook and all these other streaming
platforms so great and then there's uh
there's some of the issues with
censorship and stuff like that I don't
yeah and so you have to get your own way
you have to get your own website in your
own advertisers and stream directly to
there just to make sure that you can
retain your sovereignty that's what I do
I'm even transferring off patreon
because I don't want to worry about that
you know um but we have this opportunity
you and I can say anything we want and
nobody can stop us there's no there's no
company between
and the audience yeah good it's good
yeah yeah we can we keep looking bro
you've done yeah and what was I saying
so we're taking this knowledge that
we've learned passive energy birth
control the understanding of what
actually works for us as opposed to what
we're told should work for us and we're
taking that knowledge and going heading
back toward home
you know Whole Foods why is whole food
so successful because they don't use
pesticides because it's healthy so yeah
it's more expensive but the idea at
least is this is natural food the whole
natural movement natural childbirth
paleo movement Paleo diet intermittent
fasting wim HOF jumping in the cold
water like all these things are where we
came from
yeah evolutionary medicine is a big deal
now right yeah so I think that what's
happening that the success of sexathon
clearly was that it connected with a
yearning that people had for like why
isn't this working right I love this
person why why am i bored why am I
looking at other people right and the
resonance is oh I'm looking at other
people because that's the sort of animal
I am I am right I am an ape
I am an a we're all apes yeah and that's
what I was trying to do was civilize to
death was to take it as you said at the
beginning of this conversation they're
very similar in some ways and what I
wanted to do was civilize to death was
take that same perspective and payoff
and apply it to life in general not just
the sexual aspect exactly which I
thought was so brilliant that you took
that abstract leap to that field because
it actually puts you I think on par to
be one of the more like world leading
intellectuals in the space of trying to
get more people awaken to where our
origins are and what we can learn from
our origins as we move forward and also
like you said what we can learn from
building the cities and metropolis is
and also embed that as well into some of
our old
or ideologies and and try move forward
better like that's again this big thing
that I think I'm taking away from from
where you're endeavoring into your next
contributions to our world that I think
are actually you know helping also
awaken a lot of people too
what are some of the most important
conversations that we need to have I saw
you had Andrew yang on yeah I think
universal basic income is a very
hunter-gatherer principle universal
basic ownership or assets is the thing
you know Universal basics stake holding
is right yeah is the idea
it's very hunter-gatherer we're all in
this together we all take care of each
other and there's a great expression in
Africa
the best place to store extra food is in
your friend stomach good right how do
you think about that it makes sense we
survive by taking care of each other
that's basic to our our identity as a
species and when we lose sight of that
and we sort of externalize those
functions you know like your good
neighbor State Farm is there
give me the good neighbor I'll take the
good neighbor over the insurance company
any day yeah yeah there's some again
it's like let's see if I let's see if we
can get this like with this with this
initial question of this like ultimate
nature of reality that were that we were
starting with whatever is macro to even
the levels of microbiome here human
holding the microbiome what is holding
the room of the human civilization the
planet macro perspective there what's
happening at this ultimate nature
reality level and also like our
trajectory where we came from
hunter-gatherers what we can take from
that process what was actually really
good there those ideas there what could
we take that as good from the cities and
from the metropolis is that we live in
what can we do with these two with this
evolutionary trajectory bringing these
things together to move
forward in a way that's more optimal and
in a way that understands the macro
perspective of what is the purpose of
this experience and where should we be
going that is most optimal that
maximizes flourishing that makes it so
that more people can come and endeavor
into consciousness and maximize their
creativity and have meaning and have
love and have that that seems to be the
function and another part of it seems to
be that you use science and you poke at
the initial source code that we were
created with and then instead of
thinking about things linearly you think
about them cyclically and so we've
discovered what the initial source code
is that evolved to complexity and then
we embed that initial source code in
complexity and make another cycle and
this is kind of like an Ouroboros II
style of sorcerer of creation that we're
just embedded in but we can decrease the
amounts of suffering we can increase the
amounts of flourishing and in order to
do that we have to look at our roots we
have to look at hunter-gatherers and and
and and we also have to look at what has
been good about the cities and
metropolis is the truer and today and we
have to be honest about the fact that
that not all not all advancement is
progress that not all movement is
movement in the direction we need to be
going and until we question some of the
fundamentals this faith-based belief in
progress then we're not able to think
about what do we want to keep and what
do we want to abandon right it's not
just this this sort of panicky
insistence that we Revere everything
that we've done like no that's nonsense
we we are capable of picking and
choosing yes right you know in my
opinion solar wind energy great great
idea geothermal works beautifully a
nuclear I don't see it head to nuclear
fusion though maybe but do we need it
because I think one of the one of the
Savalas that we need to question is this
idea that growth is necessary a turn we
need to constantly be grow
economies need to be growing this is a
very agricultural post agricultural view
because agricultural societies are in
this ratcheting process that population
keeps growing so you need more land you
need more intense cultivation techniques
you need more food because the
population keeps growing it's it's it
just spins right hunter-gatherer
societies are sustainable you have a
steady population it ebbs and flows with
changes in the environment the natural
environment and so it's sort of a
steady-state situation I think one of
the lessons that people are most
resistant to but that I think is most
essential to the kind of world that you
were just describing is the realization
that maybe 500 million people on this
planet is the right number that's where
that's the Georgia Guidestones number is
it yeah I just I just pulled that up I
didn't know so million is the Georgia
Guidestones number 500 million people
living harmoniously with nature right
the oceans the you know the the the with
that amount of people on the planet we
wouldn't probably be interfering with
natural processes right so we're heading
there in some senses with the population
stabilization you can look at the canary
in the coalmine image man yeah only in
in developed countries that is religious
and also writing less developed have are
more religious and less developed have
more kids right and if those countries
were living the way in terms of resource
consumption the way people and yeah you
know Spain and Japan we're living then
yeah the world would be pretty bad so I
think you know that's why I look at the
universal basic income or some sort of
you know global security system yeah so
that you disincentivize people from
having lots of kids in order to have
some security and old age if they knew
like oh I don't need to do that we
already know we're women
are allowed to be educated and have
decision-making they have far fewer
children so if you had like a universal
movement in the direction of respect for
women women allow to make their own
reproductive choices and incentives to
not have kids you know I'm not talking
about eugenics I'm not talking about
killing anybody or any crazy stuff like
that yeah I'm just saying make it
beneficial for people to have fewer kids
make it you know I don't have kids I
talk about it all the time on my podcast
like I love not having kids I'm really
glad I love kids
other people's kids and I wish I lived
in a tribal situation where I could take
care of those kids sometimes and let my
friends go off and go to the movies and
share that yeah and in fact I'm in the
process of setting up a situation like
that and that it's really interesting I
want to know more about that can you
give us any sneak peeks into that
yeah I'm not ready to say where it is
yeah yeah because I'm I'm it's still
very early but I'm in the process I
thought bland there mm-hmm and my
closest friends I want to give them the
opportunity to come and buy land and get
in on this and once they've decided what
they want to do then I'm gonna talk
about it publicly and let people who
listen to my podcast or your podcast or
whatever if they're interested come it's
a very it's a beautiful place
it's very cheap yes yes clean air clean
water proximity of nature big airport
not too far away yes yes and what we're
basically it's not a communist everyone
you buy your own place build your own
house do it but there's no building code
so you can live in a yurt you can build
a teepee you can build a normal house
you can do two straw-bale an Earthship
whatever whatever you want and the idea
is that we take care of each other yeah
that's it so you have kids then you want
to go to the city for the weekend sure
we'll watch your kids you know you want
to take off and
Airbnb your place fine we'll be around
we'll do it we'll watch your dogs when
we take off you take care of a it's very
basic
you know we grow spinach you grow apples
that's it we have friends who do
chickens so we have another friend who's
an auto mechanic he'll fix our cars you
know whatever we so you this might sound
like communism to some people it might
sound like hippy you know kommune i
think these things work on small scales
they don't yeah you know anarchy doesn't
scale it works when there's reputational
damage it works when we all know each
other and if you act like an [ __ ]
everybody knows and somebody talks to
you and says hey dude that wasn't cool
and then you know that's an organic way
for us to interact as people when you
scale up to the level beyond Dunbar's
number which you're familiar with you
all right
when you get past that other people
become abstractions reputational damage
and no longer functions and you get
someone who you know rips people off
yeah the self dealing habits come and
this has actually been something we've
talked about the show with our eNOS I'm
and a bunch of other young people that
are also pushing into this field of
creating communities of about a hundred
and fifty people each and then having
those communities be take some of these
hunter-gatherer habits and communal
habits into them and then also interface
with the with the growing tech world and
interface with other communities right
in that sense so and that's that's the
thing where technology's been really
helpful right because more and more
people don't need to be in a given place
it can work remotely and so if you're
making 100 grand a year you want to live
in Silicon Valley or you want to live in
Idaho because then I don't know you're
rich in Silicon Valley you're poor right
so the operate in Silicon Valley or
closer to the network effect and so
you're closer to people that are higher
up on this intelligence Fitness
landscape but then again how often are
you actually interfacing with them
versus you know they're not in your
technical den dumb bar number maybe
right and what are you aspiring to what
are you inspiring to do you wanna be as
rich as possible financially or you just
want to be quality of life
and I think these are not mutually
exclusive things in the sense that you
can aspire to network with the some of
the smartest people in the world and
maybe you do find them in the Silicon
Valley or London or whatever I'm
questioning that problem I do too in a
sense um I do too in a sense all over
the world yeah you've been smartest
people I haven't been in Silicon Valley
in your podcast yes sir excellent your
presentations are excellent as well and
so I agree that um that like it's not
like everyone that works at Google or
Facebook is [ __ ] brilliant
right and actually a lot of the time we
see that some of the smartest people
that we've had the chance to sit down
with some of the most spiritually
activated and actualized and
interconnected with nature and most also
interconnected with science and most
entrepreneurial people are the ones that
are off the grid that are way less can
into the indoctrinate into the
metropolis and and and that style of of
they're not people that are trying to
like get rich they're people that are
trying to help awaken and like catalyze
spiritual actualization and and unity
with nature and and spreading that style
of vibe around and asking some of these
grand philosophical questions with our
merging with AI and the technological
singularity so I think people like that
are some of the smartest people and
sometimes they're found in metropolis
sometimes they're not
but you mentioned this just a couple
minutes ago and I just want to
illustrate it because I think it helps
so much that if you believe that that
that when you look at hunter-gatherers
compared to the metropolis to where
we're at today that if you look at that
and you say that there's nothing good
about hunter-gatherers and there's a
hundred percent good about metropolis
and cities you are sadly mistaken we ask
you to please reconsider
that aspect of your worldview look back
at hunter-gatherers look back at their
interconnectedness with nature look back
at their interconnectedness with each
other and some of their best practices
and try and go back and fetch those best
practice
and embed them in what we have now today
right and get rid of some of the
cancerous aspects to our civilization
today include inclusive steak holding
include the future of our social fabric
that can maximize flourishing and that
can potentially look like some of these
small interconnected communal situations
that we're really excited for that and
hopefully we can revisit more
conversations like this I hope that like
i said when you visit or like we said
when you visit schirmer's podcast in
future when he comes on yours you're
going down here on his next yeah so when
that happens do we did this the second
time that we hosted sure Morano sure we
did our best to help zap a little bit of
that hunter-gatherer nature spirit into
him and it actually did a decent did a
good job
he resonated with it so um the more that
we can do that and the more that we can
illustrate out like here are here are
ways that both you know Pinker Shermer
Dawkins have great things that are be
said and also some of the good you know
christopher ryan things that are being
said around hunter-gatherers and graham
hancock stuff can actually be embedded
and intertwined together or yeah yeah
the truth is always somewhere in the
middle right and there's always as long
as you're coming into the conversation
with respect for the research for the
data and you know not imposing your
worldview on it I think yeah it's always
useful I my conversations with Michael
Shermer have always been interesting and
respectful anyway yeah I totally like I
think he's laughing legit dude yeah yeah
um two quick questions on the way out
that we ask all of our guests the first
question is do you think we're in a
simulation I think we may be someone's
dream does that count
yeah we may be in a dream why do you
think that because because I
you know how when your dream meeting and
maybe there's smoke nearby and you start
dreaming a fire you integrate this thing
that's happening in the external world
into your dream or an alarm goes off and
suddenly you're in school and the bells
ringing you know your dream incorporates
these things I've had experiences in my
life that felt like they were
incorporations
of something that was happening in
another dimension and it was being
incorporated into my consciousness here
I don't know if that is comprehensible
absolutely yeah yeah I've had
experiences that are inexplicable we
still don't know what is going on with
sleep we know that we're clicking the
Save button we know that it's really
important for a biological physiology
and stuff but we don't know what's
happening with the theory of parallel
universes and the multiverses and what's
actually happening with where we're
going with we don't know why it's
essential we I mean some animals sleep
with half their brain and you know
there's all sort hypnosis we don't
understand placebo we don't know there's
a lot of gravity we don't understand I
was talking with Joe and he said he
mentioned that to Neil and Neil got
really defensive like we can measure it
we yeah but the fact that you can
measure something doesn't mean you
understand it right it doesn't mean you
understand how it works you know free
until the 1970s no one understood how
aspirin worked we could measure it you
take more aspirin you feel less pain
like you can measure it's a fact but
that doesn't mean you understand the
mechanism it doesn't mean you understand
what's going on it just means you do
this that happens okay fine that's not
understanding you know and I think that
a lot of our approach to understanding
life is like that it's like well you can
measure it that doesn't mean you
understand it I've one of my mentors is
Stanley Crippler who's spent his life
studying parapsychology and he's done
all sorts of interesting research and
dreams and myths and
you know extra sensory perception and
all this kind of stuff so I've spent a
lot of time talking with him about those
things but yeah I've had expressed on
the show yeah well he's well into his
80s he's in his eighties yes he based in
Fairfax Fair about north of San
Francisco okay cool maybe we're gonna
see him in a couple days cool cool yeah
he maybe it would be cool to maybe visit
him on site or if he's down in the area
we could maybe have him on yeah I'd love
to I took him down to Rogen and you did
it yeah he was on Rogen show oh yeah
that's great it was fun he's he's an
amazing dude i he hung out with like you
know people I'm sure you're very
interested in he was the youngest of
that crowd of Timothy Leary and Aldous
Huxley and
Alan Watts like he knew all these people
yes so cool Joseph Campbell be great
he'd be a great person amplified the
messages more around the world of what
yes he's he's really sweet dude - yes
he's wonderful
yeah I'll put you in touch with him um
but yeah so I I couldn't dream that this
is a dream and occasionally something
from the other dimension pops in deja
Vu's all this yeah okay the last
question that we like to ask our guests
is what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the world
itself you know there's a reason that
nature touches us there's a reason that
it's just to me a sunset the waves
rolling up on the beach of a woman's
body
music these things are all pieces of one
thing they're all the same I was talking
to an ethnomusicologist on my podcast
and he made the point that like you know
someone asked me recently what is that
he said it really interesting it was
like the Delta what's the greatest delta
between your Under
ending of a thing in your appreciation
of a thing ah
and I said music mmm because I don't
understand music at all I cheated don't
love it yeah I feel it so much or
reality for that if you're gonna go
macro yeah everything yeah that's a lot
of good answer but yeah it's like this
Delta between how much we respect
reality and how much we understand it
like we love reality from some a lot of
us but we I don't know if I love reality
there are aspects of reality I could do
without let me tell you but yeah I feel
like you know for me a book like this is
it's a love letter to to the natural
world because I feel like yes that's you
know every dog yearns for the days when
he was a wolf yeah you know every every
fish in an aquarium is yearning for the
ocean like there's a reason those things
resonate with us it's because that's
where we came from that's what created
us right if there's a God that created
human beings
it was the African savannah the 500,000
years ago right that was what made us
and so there's a reason golf courses are
so relaxing to our minds because we look
at that and we see the world we're meant
to and have habit yeah and so yeah I
feel like you know it's that's why
though top viewed channels right now in
this is what I've learned about China
have you ever seen our primitive
technologies YouTube channels the ones
where it's literally the videos of the
guys that go out like hunter-gatherers
and they build like houses and make
shoes and stuff like that out of all the
stuff that you find in the woods and and
like stuff like that that's actually
some of the most popular channels here
and it's apparently the most popular
viewership in China really so literally
civilization as it's moving into
metropolis and cities
mrs. hunter-gatherer society so much
that it becomes the most popularly
viewed things on the Internet
right but that's the tragedy right that
we destroy the real the the real thing
and then we sell with commercials and
plastic packaging some cheap copy of
that thing that's what we do we pollute
the water and then we sell bottled water
we pollute the air and then we sell air
filters for your bedroom this is the
trajectory of civilization that I'm
hoping we're turning away from and
you're saying wait a minute instead of
creating air filters rain yeah like we
throw out into cities and metropolis
gather what we learned from that
experience we come back to nature and
they integrated this exactly I hope I
hope that's where we're going it's
better than that Mad Max thing Chris
this has been so fun brother thank you
so much for coming on the show yeah
happy to show freaking and lightning
really appreciate you coming on and
congratulations on all the incredible
work that you've done with sex at dawn
with civilized everyone highly highly
recommend checking out all the links in
the bio below chris ryan PhD dot-com is
the website also civilized to death the
book link is in the bio below check that
out sex at dawn also the book link is in
the bio below I read the audio book too
yeah so if my voice doesn't annoy you
anyone an audiobook there you go hit
that audio book as well you guys know we
definitely are big fans of audiobooks
definitely that's a great point he you
narrated it which is great also check
out his Twitter his Instagram and
Facebook as well
I'm follow along the journey again the
podcast is called tangentially speaking
they've had over 400 episodes check that
out it's done from his van
well sometimes sometimes from the van
yeah the van through Paula G as Chris is
doing I love that the scarlet johansson
is such a funny name
love that check all that out everyone
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about the concepts that we talked
about in the show about what aspects of
progress may actually be analogous to
disease and about how we can then like a
boomerang start with this nature and
interconnectivity go out find what was
good in the cities of
let's bring it back to this nature and
interconnectedness I love love this
conversation so much again for also for
all of those listening and checking us
out we would love for you to support the
artists the entrepreneurs the leaders in
your communities that you believe then
support them and help them grow support
simulation our show all of our links
BIRT below to our paypal patreon
cryptocurrency can find all those links
below support us and also that's it
everyone build the future manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in well